all right let's bring in Daniel Jeremiah
the NFL Network and he is the radio
analyst for the Chargers game do you
have an update on Melvin Gordon Daniel
no Dan I haven't made it down for coffee
yet
still up in the room but I did I did
just hop on Twitter and see Sea
Shepherd's tweet so it'll be nice to see
what what goes on I imagine he'll get
out there and warm-ups and trying to
tell everybody that he can that he can
play but sounds like it's still TBD to
me well I know it's an important game
because it's against the Chiefs and but
it it's important for him to be
healthier when you need him to be
healthier so I don't know what the
risk/reward is with the with Gordon
tonight trying to play in this game yeah
I think some people tried to make this
others like it's a winner-take-all you
know lose a repeal match and I don't you
know I don't feel that way to me I just
come down the most important thing is
you get into the tournament which I
think but you know both these teams are
gonna get in the playoffs and the second
most important thing even more so than
home-field advantage for me is that you
have your key players healthy and ready
to go
and there's a Chargers team that's
proven they can went on the road so you
know I don't know if it's close if it's
questionable if you're rush it with
Melvin Gordon as opposed just taking
your time because it is a Thursday game
you've got you play next Saturday so you
got Lisa you know it's more than a week
but you get the Ravens the following
Saturday if it was close to me I would I
would probably just wait and get it back
for that game and the thing about this
Chargers team man is you've got a chance
to get impact healthy if you take your
time getting all the Gordon back healthy
and and nobody's been talking about
Hunter Henry potentially coming back at
the end of the season those would be two
nice pieces to add at the end of the
campaign the Chargers will win tonight
if if they can protect Phillip Rivers I
think if they can protect Phillip Rivers
especially you know kind of on the edges
when you look at what the Chiefs can
bring with you Cindy forward and really
Chris Jones who can rush outside or
inside if those guys can't get home and
get pressure on Phillip Rivers I think
Phillip Rivers has a very good chance of
carving up the secondary so that's gonna
be the challenge by the Chargers more of
an offensive team or a defensive team I
think they're really balanced you know I
think they're what the
fifth rated offense and they're in the
top ten defense spell I think the Chiefs
are a little bit more lopsided you know
obviously as an offensive team so it'll
be a good it'll be a good there's gonna
be a fun game no doubt but it'll be a
good challenge tonight to see how his
defense has progressed from the first
time they played you know having Joey
Bosa in this meeting I think what we big
not having him the first meeting who
goes farther in your opinion the Rams of
the Chargers well I mean I look Dan I
get I get a check every two weeks from
one of them so I probably should feel at
that one with with the Chargers I mean I
see I think the the AFC and the NFC and
it's it's it's difficult I I can make a
strong case for either one of them I
just the good thing for the Rams does
not look positive on their on their side
of things is you know they're I have to
go play in an environment like they had
to play in the other night in Chicago
they're gonna be a much different
environment I shoot I hope they're I
hope that we a chance to my team both at
the very end of the dance there correct
yeah but I didn't want PC from you no
look I'll tell you what this charges he
when they get fully healthy Dan I really
do believe and I watch them every week
there's a lot of talent and it just
seems like you know you have to have a
year where things kind of go your way
you saw some of those bounces go their
way in Pittsburgh I mean you get your
Chargers team from Southern California
you play a game in London with perfect
weather you play game in Cleveland with
perfect weather
you play team in Pittsburgh it was like
50 degrees outside December it's like
everything kind of gone their way so I
say that and it's supposed to be wet
rainy tonight so maybe that's when it
changes with us talking to Daniel
Jeremiah NFL Network analyst also he's
the color analyst for the Chargers on
radio and you look at Patrick mahomes
why is he making it look so easy
he's been unbelievable I mean I tried to
explain to somebody the other day of how
to describe Patrick mahomes and what
he's doing I said it's like watching
somebody win the three-point contest and
then turn on the dunk contest because
he's he's showing you all the precision
that you would see you know from an
accuracy standpoint and then just the
jaw-dropping Wow athletic you know
acrobatics throws like trick shot throws
almost I mean it's it's incredible what
he's doing in the scary thing is when
you take somebody with his ability level
and was extremely wrong coming out of
college and you put him with the perfect
coach and Andy Reid to help him
fundamentally to surround him with a
scheme that fits his skills and then you
put him with the most explosive receiver
in the NFL and Terry killing and really
you know probably the best tight end in
the NFL and Kelsey that's a perfect
storm here in Kansas City
how many first-round picks will be
quarterbacks there's so many of them
haven't decided yet you know we'll see
how that goes I'll tell you what just
going through the teams the other day as
they get into this Dan's not eight teams
are in the quarterback to market so many
of these teams have their young
quarterback right now so I don't
envision it would be very many we'll see
who all comes out I would say probably I
would put it at two and a half right now
ooh
over/under a two and a half you like
that I might go over it it always feels
like there's there's a team that
surprises you I don't know if you have
any plug-and-play quarterbacks coming
out of college this year I don't know if
anybody can do what this group of
quarterbacks has done already this
season yeah I don't I don't last year's
group that's that's the fact it probably
you know the last several years we've
had pretty good groups I've still got
more to do on these guys we'll see who
all ends up declaring but you know
there's some there's some very very raw
you know guys with good tools but I
thought last year's group was much more
accomplished have fun tonight Daniel we
appreciate your time thank you that's
Daniel Jeremiah they'll be on the call
for the Chargers the radio call for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
you